Dr. Anthony Fauci did a bunch of interviews over
the weekend. He did one with Jake Tapper on CNN.
He did an interview with Chris Wallace on Fox News
and some other interviews. And one of the things
that we learned last week based on a new poll is
that 49 percent of is it 49 percent of Republicans
are male Republicans, 49 percent of one or the
other don't want the vaccine. And 47 percent of
all Trump voters don't want the vaccine. And
Dr. Anthony Fauci said on TV with Chris Wallace
that he does not get it. Let's take a listen to
what he had to say, according to a recent poll.
Forty nine percent of Republican men said
they don't intend to get the vaccine. Doctor,
how much of a difference will it make if President
Trump, who was largely responsible for the success
of Operation Warp Speed, how much of a difference
will it make if President Trump leads a campaign
for the people who are most devoted to him
to actually go out and get the vaccine?
Chris, I think it would make all the difference
in the world. He's a very widely popular person
among Republicans. If he came out and said
go and get vaccinated is really important
for your health, the health of your
family and the health of the country,
it seems absolutely inevitable that the
vast majority of people who are his close
followers would listen to him. He's such a
strongly popular person. I cannot imagine
that if he comes out that they would not get
vaccinated would be very helpful to the effort
for that to happen. I'm very surprised at the
high percentage of Republicans who say they don't
want to get vaccinated. I don't understand where
that's coming from. This is not a political issue.
So Dr. Fauci doesn't seem to get that for
a lot of these people. It is a political
issue and it's a political issue in two ways.
As I mentioned earlier, if for a year you are
told this isn't really serious, why would you
want to get a vaccine? And just as importantly,
because it is political to them as we now start to
see, we were vaccinating 800000 a day under Trump.
We got to a million a day, which is what Biden
promised. We got to a million and a half. We got
to two million a day. We're now at two point four
million a day. And we're going to three and maybe
we're going to three point five. They see that
this is an accomplishment of Joe Biden. I think
some of them simply don't want to participate in
part of being of in being part of that that no,
that is a no increasingly attributed
to what Joe Biden has been able to do.
So. Anthony Fauci, you know, maybe he's sincere in
saying he's baffled. I think he's sort of playing
coy. I think he understands perfectly why it is
that this number of people are not interested in
the vaccine. And it is exactly because of what
we saw the Trump administration due for a full
year. Dr. Fauci also appeared on NBC News. He was
asked about the exact same data and he again said
it makes absolutely no sense. It makes no sense
medically. It makes no sense in terms of being
a team player. It makes no sense economically,
because the thing that's going to recover the
economy the most quickly is going to be getting
as many people as vaccinated as possible so that
we really can turn this into something that most
people won't get at all. And almost everyone who
does get it, if vaccinated does not get serious
covid it could reduce deaths to almost none if we
had everyone vaccinated. And it is, you know,
other there are vaccines, skeptical movements
in many countries. But the way in which simply
being a Trump has completely weaponized anti vax
in a way that's. Forced from the normal stuff like
normal and vivax, as we talked about last week,
is often based on the left skepticism of Big
Pharma and on the right skepticism of government
telling them what it is they have to do. This
goes very much beyond that, and this goes to the
competing narratives that existed, the science
based narrative, mostly supported by Democrats
about what it is that should be done about
a serious pandemic and the non science based
narrative supported by Trump and many people
around him, sometimes explicitly, sometimes
implicitly about this is like the flu, 15 cases
will go to zero. What about injecting bleach?
Fouchier initially said don't wear masks. So what
about that? And all of the things that we've seen
and this is simply the logical conclusion. You
see it in the partizan divide of who it is that
wants to get vaccinated. And unfortunately, I've
said before, you're not going to get everybody
vaccinated. But if you have half of Republicans
unwilling to get vaccinated, that actually
will lead to people dying either because they
can't get vaccinated in some cases and because the
vaccines aren't 100 percent. And it'll really take
take a chunk out of us getting to herd immunity.
So it's not a viable number. More than 50 percent
of voters are going to have to get vaccinated if
we are to reach full herd immunity. And we may
not. There is no indication the government is
going to force anybody to get vaccinated. But
if increasingly venues, businesses, airlines say
after a certain date on May one, there's going to
be full availability, eligibility for vaccination,
you may start seeing airlines and concert venues
and sporting events say, as of, I don't know,
October one, November one in order to come to
an event with us, in order to fly with us or
whatever, you need proof of vaccination. I think
that that the sort of practical reality of that
may be what pushes more of these Republicans
to ultimately get vaccinated. Let me know what
you think. Am I wrong? Will they say? Well,
if JetBlue requires vaccination, I'm never
flying JetBlue. Will they go that route? I don't
know. We'll be following this story on Instagram
at David Pakman show. And you can follow
me on Instagram at David Pakman as well